he's the popular Mike Florio from pro
football talk kind enough to join us as
we talk about some of the events that
have happened will happen here where do
you want to start Mike with the news
from the NFL well you know III don't
like the fact that they're waiting a
year to take up this question of over
time changes and getting the team that
kicks off a chance to match the score if
there's a touchdown on the first drive I
don't know what's going to change in a
year I think they're just trying to push
it back for 12 months and hope that no
one's talking about it then and just
continue to ignore it because if they're
going to do it do it if you're not going
to do it then don't do it either way if
they don't need another year to figure
this out it's a pretty simple
proposition if I gave you the power to
change overtime to do anything to
overtime or keep it what would you do I
love what the XFL is planning to do Dan
it's the two-point conversion shootout
with 44 guys on the field 22 at each end
back and forth like the end of a soccer
or hockey game where you take three four
or five cracks out at each and you let
it be resolved that way it's quick it's
efficient and it's all the little affair
so just whoever got the so if you've got
a two-point conversion then I got a
two-point conversion then we just keep
going back and forth you do what the XSL
is going to do they're going to do three
rounds each and you get and if there's a
turnover it's one point for the defense
so that's a way to maybe help break the
tie and I guess it's still tied after
three rounds it's just a tie and then in
a postseason game it would keep going
but but I how compelling would that be
to have 44 guys on the field 22 at each
head just back and forth two-point
conversions do it three rounds and and
see if you break the top the pardon I
always say pardon
it's the pass interference rule and they
keep tweaking with it now of you know
the final two minutes and you know
coaches challenge are you are these
coaches challenge specific for the two
minutes the final two minutes of the
first half and the game that you can use
that challenge or do I have to keep a
challenge in my pocket from you know the
the previous time in the game no I think
you got to hold it you got it you got to
be ready you have to have a timeout
ready you have to have a coach's
challenge ready and I think that's going
to be a slaw and
this because a Rams Saints outcome could
happen and if you don't have a red flag
left or if you don't have a timeout left
to lose if you're wrong there's nothing
you can do about it and I understand why
they're doing this because it's very
easy to trigger an automatic replay
review there has to be clear and obvious
evidence that the ruling on the field
was correct to avoid an automatic review
passion or threats
there's always pushing and shoving and
jostling and you can have a situation
where there's a full-blown algorithm on
replay review five times in the final
two minutes of a half because on every
completion you have to look and see was
there possibly pass interference but it
just it's taking a situation that was a
bad solution it's making it more
complicated and I keep banging on the
sky judge video official whatever they
want to call it an eight the official
who was there to just you know break
glass in the event of emergency and say
guys you really blew it throw a flag
pick a flag up do whatever pass
interference does not need to be subject
to replay review that is too big of a
solution to a very narrow problem the
problem is every once in a while the
officials are just going to blow it and
they need to have a fallback who can
quickly fix it before you get into the
discussion of replay review in the Hail
Mary you're not going to be able to
review the Hail Mary or you can't
challenge that down date and how often
do they throw a flag on a Hail Mary it
feels like there's pass interference on
every Hail Mary how often is it flagged
well it's very rarely flagged the only
blatant pass interference I remember is
the one that wasn't like the sale Mary
from 2012 that ended the lockout of the
officials when golden pages he could
just blatantly shoved a packer from
behind and caught the pass to win the
game here's the problem with the Hail
Mary they don't want the game to be over
and then we have to wait three or four
minutes for our Veron to see whether or
not there was pass interference and and
every coach who has a red flag left what
the heck throw it out there it's the
Hail Mary - the Hail Mary maybe I get
lucky and they see pass interference
they don't want games to end that way
but how do you avoid it Dan here's
what's going to happen they're going to
come up with some sort of the definition
of what a Hail Mary is certain yardage
certain time left on the clock certain
number of guys in the end zone
and then Bill Belichick is going to come
up with a way to coach his way around it
and you're going to have to do
strategies for you right you're going to
oh geez for avoiding that situation I
mean think about it if the rule is it's
the 40-yard line or or out with 10
seconds or less left on the clock if
you're on the 40 with 10 seconds left
you throw all click out 2 yards so the
final throw to the end zone is
potentially subject to replay review and
we really want to be thinking about
those issues as a game is coming to a
conclusion so I just don't I don't think
any of its practical it makes me feel
even more strongly that next year at
this time the right way to go Adam ever
the officiating crew let that person see
what we see at home and bridge the gap
between what the officials see on the
field and what the rest of us see in HD
1080 and we know when they blow it and
that official needs to tell the referee
just blow it fix it and then move
forward quickly he's Mike Florio from
pro football talk live and pro football
talk common BC sports the situation with
the Cowboys with dak Prescott I don't
know if you pointed this out but I read
some things with Die Prescott that we
look at his contract and you know
they're gonna have to pay him thirty
million dollars a year but in three
years thirty million dollars he's going
to be the 10th highest-paid quarterback
that I don't
it's just his his turn is his turn next
man up I have more of an issue with what
I have to pay Amari Cooper in Ezekiel
Elliott than I do with dak Prescott what
are your thoughts okay well here's the
thing that we've seen with quarterbacks
over the past three or four years the
top of the quarterback Park was fixed at
about 22 million with Aaron Rodgers and
then came Andrew Luck Derek Carr Matthew
Stafford Jimmy Garoppolo Kirk Cousins
Matt Ryan Aaron Rodgers Russell Wilson
each one setting the bar higher higher
higher higher the question is now with
dak Prescott does he go higher than
Russell Wilson does this cycle continue
where the next guy up ends up being the
highest-paid quarterback in NFL history
at some point somebody's got to fall
under that but you're right as time goes
by the salary cap keeps going up TV
money keeps going up look I'm not a big
fan of doing a long term deal right now
I would try to find a way to stop it
short term because the money is going to
continue to explode the new TV deals the
new CBA
all the money the NFL figures out how it
makes for legalized damage
and you could find himself in a position
where you're quickly at the middle of a
pack or the back of the pack as these
dollars over the next three or four
years skyrocket and I think Russell
Wilson should have done a shorter term
field I've seen a lot of contracts guy
you do a six-year deal now the world is
going to be dramatically differently NFL
in three years and and I think that if
that Prescott does anything he should
try to do a short-term extension so he
can be back at the trough again when
when we see you know the salary cap at
250 million a year instead of a hundred
million a year are you doc Prescott guy
I was very impressed with what he did in
the postseason ban especially a lot to
the Rams because usually the Cowboys
have to have a zql a hitting on all
cylinders for dak Prescott to have a
good game Elliott was shut down by the
Rams and Prescott still had a good game
and and that to me tells me there's a
lot of promise there and it may be if
the Cowboys decide to kick the can by a
year they're going to regret it because
I think there's enough to believe it
back press thoughts on the verge
entering year for to becoming a guy who
doesn't need to have a running game to
have a great performance you know on any
given Sunday Monday Thursday if you were
gonna give out these franchise contracts
would you be willing to give it to dak
Prescott or Jared Goff first oh that
question I'm not I'm very skeptical
about Jared Goff and and I would not be
surprised if he doesn't get a central
contract with the Rams
you'd be surprised if he does get one
I'd be surprised if he doesn't know I
wouldn't be surprised if he does and I
got to get all my [ __ ] a chance at you
at some point he's gonna find his own
guy remember he inherited Jared Goff and
you know there may be somebody out there
too big today is eyeing at some point to
to come in and be that long-term guy
because you got to ask yourself am I
willing to commit 35 million a year to
Jared Goff or could I find a younger guy
who who I get a lot cheaper and put
pieces around and that's the biggest
problem now you have those early years
with a young quarterback where he's
dirt-cheap under the rookie weight scale
and then you have to ask yourself do we
pay huge money eventually something's
going to say we're just not going to pay
the huge money we'll go find somebody
else is the combine going to stay in
Indianapolis I know that we're moving
the draft around and it's been quite
successful but what about the combine
it's just a matter of time before the
Columbine leaves Dan I mean it's staying
for one more year beyond 2020 I think
2022 at the earliest maybe a year or two
after that they're going to turn this
thing into a travel Roadshow and
eventually they're maybe doing these
workouts before stadium full of fans
they're going to be making millions of
dollars off of it it's going to be just
like the draft I got no problem with it
in theory the NFL's found a way to
generate real revenue during the seven
months they're not playing football
games but there's a combine gonna be LA
Dallas wherever and they're going to
make a ton of money off of it just like
they always address we had Chris long
the former NFL player on yesterday
created a little bit of a stir where he
said that he smoked marijuana regularly
when he was playing I don't know if
that's a huge shocker but the fact that
he could get around the test well where
we headed did that create any buzz do
you think no pun intended he confirmed
what I've been saying for years the way
the system is set up you have one test
per year under the substance abuse
policy if you're not in the program
already you just have to shut down
smoking Middlemarch wait until you do
your one test per year the window opens
for twenty two incidentally and then
once you have that one test you're good
to go so and Chris long made a great
point in during that month you end up
taking opioids to deal with pain you end
up drinking you end up doing things
other than smoking marijuana which a lot
of people think are worse than smoking
marijuana in the first place not so
encouraged by the league's willingness
to let the medical professionals decide
whether or not this is something the
players should be allowed to do and the
one caveat is there's still several
states where the NFL has teams where
medical marijuana isn't legal yet so it
may have to slam the brakes on this to
let some of these other states that
topped it before they do it but but I'm
encouraged to see that they're willing
to let that the process play out let the
doctors look at it and maybe get to the
point where these players are allowed to
use it to deal with chronic pain thank
you Mike we appreciate your time as
always
that's a Mike Florio pro football talk
live NBC Sports NBC Sports Network for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel two
39 on DirecTV stream for free on BR live
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]